um it says breaking Texas DPS now say
there was no school police officer who
encountered or engaged the mask uh
shooter at Robb Elementary School the
shooter was not confronted before entry
and it appears he walked into the school
through an unlocked door
we got to lock the doors that seems
obvious to everyone involved the doors
of the school have to be locked you know
I showed up at my old school I was with
a friend this was years ago and I was
you know I thought I'd do like a little
homecoming like hey this is where I went
to school I thought I could walk down I
had no idea and this was years ago I had
no idea how like how shut down these
schools were it was all locked I knocked
on the door they were like hello excuse
me and Through the Glass I was like yeah
I went to school here I'm Tim Dylan yeah
I was on Joe Rogan we talked about Bill
Gates
and they they looked at me like the guy
looked at me like I was crazy showing up
at a school and now you know upon
further reflection I now I get it it
does seem crazy do you think uh though
because the locked door is inevitably
someone will get in you think at some
point what we need to do is have decoy
schools like Saddam Hussein palaces
where the students are in a decoy school
right and then we have doubles in the
other schools right but he's going to
get out which school is which well then
you gotta check you got to keep moving
like what about if we educated kids
underground underground would be like
underground we have underground cities
we have underground military bunkers
right the kids don't need sunlight they
can certainly underground we can
recreate the conditions of UV light or
the military industrial complex we'll
make a clip out of this yeah everyone
arm up and don't leave right and just
let delivery people deal with it yes
delivery people are the only brave ones
now yeah I mean I was talking about that
today somebody on instacart delivered me
two candles they had to take that long
walk
from the door to the wall to their car
into Walgreens parking lot depending on
the time of day in Los Angeles that
ain't nothing that's nothing you have no
idea what could happen on your weight I
guarantee you an instacart or Postmates
worker on the way to the car has met
their end yeah or release a new virus
for our own safety to get us back
indoors you just see a burrito fall to
the floor and then blood yeah because
that people that leave their houses now
really are the the most Brave yeah and
it's gonna be
they're the most brave people they're up
they're outside teachers maybe are more
Brave than cops now I mean teachers
teaching might be a more deadly job than
police gotta arm them yeah you gotta arm
these kindergarten teams well here's the
deal in Texas why didn't they have gun
I'm not even kidding like why did they
not have guns in Texas like is this all
the gunman's fault or can we lay a
little bit of blame on the teachers who
weren't carrying these cucks moving from
California that's what it is is you have
a bunch of liberal teachers moving from
California don't have guns and aren't
focused on the defense of the school and
it's not just enough to have guns again
I I just want to focus right we need
body armor because the other guy and
that is what's being seriously suggested
yeah well you need body armor because
the guy's gonna come if he's got a
bigger gun he's prepared he's got the
guy I watch a lot of self-defense videos
right the perp always has the advantage
right because he's the one that comes in
and goes we're doing this right you have
to go oh [ __ ] we're doing this because
you he he has the element of surprise
the element of surprise and he may have
an AR-15 those things are pretty
efficient they do their job so what we
need is well let's let's plan this out
we one student we need one teacher at
the chalkboard handgun maybe ready in
the one hand then we need another
teacher so you're saying just a teacher
pretty much all day
at the at the ready well you don't know
if the kids got a gun so you got to have
one whoa you gotta have a gun facing the
kids that's right and then you have to
have someone watching your blind spot so
we need another teacher a teacher's
eight if you will teach his age they
don't even need to walk to the store we
just need two armed people in each
classroom one watching the door one
watching the windows AR-15 drawn
it's not a bet I guess we have two we
have two people in the classroom they
each have an AR-15 out yeah and it'll
look and it's just got a fun way to
quiet the kids down too quiet down it's
nap time yeah yeah now the kids
themselves may be armed because it's
their right yes but
as long as you have an AR-15 you have
the advantage because their little hands
can't quite grasp or deal with the
pushback of an AR-15 yeah and you can
take a few of them out if you need to if
you need to you'll get a few so if we if
we this because now we're fine we need
to live in the last scene of a Quentin
Tarantino movie where everyone's
pointing guns at each other at all times
we're finding the Common Ground here and
this is what I want to stress so if you
have a few people in each classroom with
AR-15s one trained on the kids one on
the door of the classroom and one of the
teacher because you don't know what
they're going through oh it's a great
point because the teacher might flip out
so you need you need one kid Marshall
yes in the class so a kid Marshall with
a gun yeah
who has a gun on the teacher you need
two teachers aides with AR-15s one at
the door one at the class yes
interesting yes it's not a bad idea and
you need school uniforms and those
uniforms are body armor
Kevlar
yes
15 at the teacher AR-15 at the door
problem solved not a big deal not a
tough way to live at all it's fine it's
totally comfortable and the most
important part reasonable right right
and people in other countries would
watch this and they would they would
think it's comedy but what it actually
is is a good plan it's a great smart
thought out cogent plan it's not a bad
idea not at all yeah otherwise we're
going to be just relying on what we're
relying on now which I guess is Chance
happenstance luck yeah yeah because now
it seems like a casino a little bit if
you send your kids to school yeah no I
was a little bit of a casino even in
supermarkets I would feel a lot safer
yes or armed I would feel a lot safer if
the Army was there while I got lettuce
if the if the military could potentially
enforce a barrier around the supermarket
and check people as they went in yeah we
need military checkpoints at Safeway I
don't think it's a bad idea I don't
think so I put the military outside
Supermarket I don't think so at all